[Music]
Julie Fayette rich roll back on the
podcast thanks for inviting me back on
we're long overdue for a conversation
well I'm glad you think so
I've been wondering when you were gonna
invite me back now I'm kidding well
we've been sharing conversations from
our retreats that's true so you've made
appearances on the show in that regard
but it's been a while since we did a
formal proper one at home this is true
so the way this usually goes is I
approach Julie a couple days before our
scheduled appointment and I say let's
talk about what we're gonna talk about
and you go yeah yeah yeah and I go yeah
yeah yeah and then we never do it and
then we sit down and we just roll
usually so that kind of is usually
preceded by a by a small spat argument
of energy of of you wanting it to be
figured out in me wanting to let it go
that's the typical that's the typical
cycle that we're on but I think we're
experiencing some deep evolution because
there was none of that this time I'm
letting go you are I'm so beautiful
well I'm moving in your direction are
you moving in mine I think so I actually
feeling like I wanted some structure you
did what we were thinking I don't know I
was just waiting for the inspiration but
well let's kind of launch into this with
one thought which is we are coming off
of an incredible energy output over the
last six to nine months
pushing books out into the world
retreats travel speaking engagements
ramping up the podcast like all of these
things have been amazing experiences
that have really enhanced our lives I
think and helped us to you know connect
with a lot of people in a meaningful way
but it's a lot of energy and I found
myself to be burned-out is not the right
word but but definitely spread too thin
and a little bit more exhausted than I
would like well I think that really
if you characterize it really correctly
or more authentically it's really when
this entire journey of wellness began
between you and me or with you and me so
I would say that it began really in 2013
or maybe even 2012 when it really
started to sort of turn and here we are
2018 right that is the year so I think
it's all of that time because we had
been what I call benched which is a is
my description of being dismantled and
unable to really function in the world
or be accepted by the world or find a
way to plug in and what happened is
after that energy lifted and we were
able to move I'd say we've both been
moving right we've been sort of thrilled
so your your window is looking back six
years yeah it has been that I mean I
think as soon as there was an
opportunity to move forward we both kind
of dove in of course at first and
haven't looked back yeah but it's just
been a constant like forward forward
forward forward what's next what's next
what's next okay what can we do like I
think we were just so so grateful to
have the opportunity to express
ourselves after what we had endured for
so many years that I mean for myself
there's almost like a fear of slowing
down like I don't want to slow down like
it was so hard for so long now
everything is working like I just want
to build build build build build in my
you know my sort of default mode is like
work harder you know push harder or is
bad or is better if this is working
let's do more let's double down on this
and I can look at that and say well
that's part of my success equation or
learning how to leverage that aspect of
my personality for growth and for good
has benefited me but it has a dark side
as well because I don't always know how
to modulate that or dial back on the
volume and I think when I do do that or
when I'm forced to do that then I
experience
fear like well if I slow down the world
is going to pass me by or whatever right
and so I get stuck into this
unsustainable model of like content
creation that I think has left me a
little bit fried lately right and I
think I mean listen I mean when you've
been benched for nine years and almost
been completely annihilated in every way
the way that we were it's appropriate
you know we then then the platform
opened up and we were able to move into
it and we've done it like in complete
joy complete merging with our authentic
voice I think we've kept it really real
I think we've kept it you know really
raw and really vulnerable and really
true to who we both are and then there
comes a time when we have to understand
and I take this more in our marriage
together is life is about evolution and
we are always evolving and changing and
so if we stick or hold on to one station
too hard or too fast or hold on too
tightly or grip too tightly there's
going to be some stagnation with that
you know the energy is going to stop
flowing and so the conversation between
you and me as hot as husband and wife
has been how do we evolve together past
an 18 year you know commitment age in
your marriage or almost 20 you know how
does that evolve and what does that look
like and so I think this is about
evolution and I think the way that it's
very relevant to what's going on in
wellness or in the social media stage
today is that you know the ocean there
is a tide that comes in and comes out
and there are waves that come in and
come out and so you know years ago I did
like every Tony Robbins seminar before I
met you like I was walking on fire and
doing like all the financial mastery and
everything that he offered and at the
time I'm sure he's evolved a lot but at
the time the thing that he didn't really
address was the natural cycle of life
the natural rhythm of life and so if we
if we don't take those times to
replenish to reboot to reconsider to
fill back up and
we tend to start sharing in my
experience from a need to be busy or
that fear of not stopping and the
authentic message becomes compromised
you know or the truth of where you are
so what do you think about that
yeah well I'm somebody who wants it to
be high tide all the time you know like
I want to deny the natural cycle of
tides going in and out right and so it's
like okay it's high tide let's keep it
at high tide as long as possible and I'm
reluctant to kind of step back and and
allow that ebb and flow to occur so
that's like my growth opportunity right
like that's that's the thing I need to
look at and acknowledge and accept and
understand that that my reluctance to
embrace that comes from a place of fear
and that fear is rooted in this idea
that if I take my foot off the gas pedal
that it's all gonna go away right and
and somebody who's been really helpful
in walking me through this in addition
to yourself is Rob Bell like I've had
long conversations with him about this
because he'll do his podcast for a while
and then he'll disappear like to make
something right - like recharge his
batteries or write a play or a novel or
I mean the guy is like just a font of
creative output it's insane and he's
like yeah I go away it's okay
and then I come back and everyone's
psyche then I'm back you should take a
break and I'm like I can't take a break
I can't what if I I can't say I've never
missed a week in the pot cat like I'm
I'm not in a place where I'm like okay
I'm gonna take a break don't worry I'm
not doing that that's not what I'm
saying
but I think there's a lot of wisdom in
having this you know self-assuredness
that you can step back and take care of
yourself and if you don't do that
ultimately it's impacting what you're
trying to accomplish in the long run
anyway so to recognize that evan flow to
have the self-confidence the assuredness
to walk away from time-to-time to
emphasize self-care or appreciate the
ebb and flow or to attune your attention
to other things in your life that are
Fortin I think is absolutely crucial and
critical especially if you want to be
you know productive for the long if you
want to be alive long term let's just
let's just call it like that I mean I
think you know it's not just it's not
just you it's the culture it's what the
culture puts on you you know more is
better competition you gotta you know
get yours while the getting's good
you know if you don't grab this
opportunity then someone else is going
to take it all of those those isms are
those beliefs that are in the planetary
grid that make us beyond the hamster
wheel and be making movements and
actions that may not be in alignment
with who we are or may not be really in
truth of who we are and like your friend
Rob Bell asked my friend - my friend -
now after the plant power Italia retreat
and releasing the cookbook I actually
got back into town and I could feel the
similar energy that descended in or came
over us in 2007 and that was at the
beginning of the dismantling phase or
the benching as I call it where I'm
benched
I could feel it I could sense it in my
body and what that told me was don't
post on social media so I'm coming I'm
actually just on the tail end of a good
two-month break what did that feel like
specifically it's like I've described on
the podcast before like I say if you've
been dismantled and this isn't a
dismantling in the same way what it is
is it's an opportunity for evolutionary
growth and when it shows up it's a
feeling of I call it the universal
faucet is turned off it's just a pause
it feels like everything is suspended in
midair and I even tried to post like on
our anniversary I had a beautiful image
that our friend Kurt Arrigo took when we
were together in Venice this gorgeous
photo and I wrote this long thing about
us and literally men of my systems would
allow me to post it like the technology
just refused me and I'm might try to and
it like and after like three or four I
should say just to like interrupt that
you walk around with
omitting some kind of like frequency
that makes all of technology in your
orbit fail even at the beginning of this
podcast we had trouble getting the
cameras set up like they weren't working
properly because you carry no some
frequency that makes all of that fritz
out like I don't know it's it's some
resonance but the thing is is so I told
you is our anniversary we met actually
to do a ceremony together and to meet
and have dinner and have time and I told
you I'm sorry that I didn't post
anything I actually had spent three
hours and it didn't it just didn't come
to fruition so I'm mature enough and
I've been through that enough that I
know what that is and that is stop do
not do that
you're not to do that so a lot of my
friends have been reaching out really
I'm loved
oh honey no I got it I don't even
whatever no you know you understood when
I talked to you but a lot of my friends
reached out to me and have been you know
we're really concerned and you must be
going through a lot and you know all
this kind of stuff in it because you
took a break from yeah because I'm not
posting and I'm not there and the thing
is is that this is such a beautiful time
for me because it's not it's not intense
like it was before and I know the signs
I know the cues so I know that this is a
moment that I'm able to step into the
void and to gain insights awarenesses
reclaim parts of myself so that I can
refine what my offerings are creatively
so they are truly in alignment with what
I came here to do and each of us that is
our main mission is to fully live our
own individual design in real truth
so it's been amazing and I'm not all the
way through it but I've had a lot of
awarenesses and a lot of things that
have you know gifts that I've been
grabbing the main thing that I've
noticed with you over the last year is
you have really stepped into your
creative powers and I'm seeing somebody
who is definitely much more expressed
than you have been in the past and I see
with that in a
opening like sort of stronger sense of
self and I think it's been an
interesting journey and path because for
many years you know I was the first
person to kind of get Wrecking you know
I was getting a lot of recognition for
they're more famous they may let's just
say they were kind of like you know in
the shadow like you know as oh she cooks
the food her what you know I'm just like
Hello like none of this would have
happened without like all the stuff that
I did and I think there was some you
know like some some level of frustration
about that not because you had a desire
to be publicly acknowledged but more
because you felt like you were you were
being muted in what you had to offer and
what I've seen it last year is you
really owning your own strengths and
capabilities and your own path and
stepping into that with your podcast and
the books not just the books that you're
writing with the music and and just the
way you carry yourself so I you know I
feel like you're you're you're so much
more fully expressed and and you're
happier as a result of that like here
you're more fully actualized in the
things that you want to be doing so talk
to me a little bit about like how you
yeah so I mean I think again that this
is all divine timing like you're in my
Union whatever we're doing here on a
higher level on a human level this is
the timing that was laid out so you were
supposed to go first in this scenario
and by you going first you've opened the
doors and opened so many people to be
willing and able to hear what it is that
I'm sharing and so we've experienced
this on a retreat yeah that was
completely frustrating to me like beyond
because you know for me this has been an
entire spiritual evolution it's required
ceremony it's required ritual heart
intention holding you in your highest
essence also you know all the children
raising the kids and fighting to save
the house and everything else that that
we experience
so when Sanjay Gupta picked up your
story and it was basically sort of
described as dude hits middle aged and
loses you know 50 pounds or whatever it
was like I tell the story like I almost
my serial out across the table because
that part of the story was just the
membrane it was only the top but the way
that our culture is and in order for us
to affect change that is the portal that
people could access what was really
going on and so it's all been completely
in an in divine timing it wasn't because
I was in some paralysis and couldn't
access my power it's because this is the
way it was meant to unfold and so yeah
I'm in a moment now that I am finally
coming into the embodiment of everything
that I came here to do and it's a super
exciting time for me and thank you for
that recognition yeah so walk me through
your your daily routine your regimen or
specifically how you spend your morning
well I'm uh I'm in a lot of flow right
now so I wouldn't even say that I have I
don't have a discipline I'm not
disciplined I'm tuned into the flow of
energy and so I'm often it depends you
know it depends on what's going on but
I'm in meditation in channeling music
I'm receiving sounds and tones
spontaneously in meditation so I'm not
looking to write a song in a traditional
way so I'm in an exploration in the
music for sure I mean this happens in
the early morning so this is what's good
you get up like at an ungodly hour you
get up at like 4:00 4:30 yeah usually
typically and then that starts an entire
process actually so it's a way of
getting up it's getting up in reverence
it's bathing my body in reverence almost
as a ritual it's preparing to sit in
meditation it's receiving the tea as
communion with the trees with the planet
connecting with this energy then I'll
move into music and then I'll start
playing and writing so I've been writing
some new music and allowing some new
music to come in but what I would say is
key about everything that I'm doing is
it's created from first a place of
ceremony which connects with and
recognizes all the energy that
is unseen which is a partner or a
co-creator in everything that ends up
being seen and this was what I was doing
behind the scenes of Ultraman of finding
ultra of our entire life for so many
years right one of the things you've
been talking about pretty regularly
lately is this importance of of ceremony
and ceremony as this almost lost art
that is so so much an integral part of
human evolution and the development of
culture over the years you know
regardless of if you look back
anthropologically at any tribe at any
you know sort of indigenous culture
ceremony is very much a central part of
daily life and in our modern developed
world we've really moved away from
ceremony in almost every regard and I
think that that's that's a loss and it's
something that I think creates this void
in our experience and leaves us perhaps
even unconsciously searching for
something that mimics that you know
trigger that's deep inside of us to you
know have that kind of thing in our life
and and I want to hear your thoughts
about that because I know you have a lot
of thoughts on that but that kind of
came up for me the other day there was a
article in The New York Times it was on
the front page of the sunday review it's
a big deal and it was the title was
something like you know podcast
Burroughs want to optimize your life and
it was an article about this movement of
podcasters in the health and
quote-unquote like life optimization
sector who have developed large
audiences and it mentions people like
Joe Rogan and Tim Ferriss and Lewis
Howes and Aubrey Marcus all of people
you know all people I know and you know
I consider myself part of that community
although I wasn't mentioned in the
article and I have like a conflicting
perspective on it because on the one
hand it was a little bit snarky it was a
little bit Kondos
like the use of bro terminology and how
these people are sort of you know
shilling self-help techniques etc but
fundamentally beneath that was this
thesis that with the kind of crippling
of religious institutions people are
searching for spirituality in new in
different ways and this podcast space is
filling that void for a certain part of
the population and I think that's right
I think that's correct and I think it
does speak to this lack of ceremony or
this modern Gestalt that were in that
has moved us away from the importance of
collective community-based ceremony that
is part and parcel of what makes us
human yeah and I mean I would I would
even go to say it's very individual
it's very personal so I'd say the reason
that is very true and the reason is
because we are spiritual beings having a
human experience or possibly
multi-dimensional beings having a
simultaneous experience so there's only
part of us is it that is experiencing
life in this physical form and what's
happened the reason that we've gotten
away from it is because of religions
because of dogmas doctrines rules
sinning you know all these kind of
things that can be the cage of religion
or dogma of religion and when ritual or
ceremony is something as natural as
walking out in nature and so what I'm
sharing is that you don't need a priest
or a guru or anybody to give you
permission to commune with that part of
yourself that is not physicalized and in
fact I encourage that you don't that you
don't use any systems that exist any
systems that exist on this planet that
have been done in traditions are
infiltrated with suppressive suppressive
energy so it's much more natural and
authentic if you can be childlike and do
what is what you feel do what is natural
to you so if you have
that you want to foster or a
relationship a dream a garden a sacred
idea anything simply sitting and
communing with that asking for the
unseen energy that is maybe your
multi-dimensional part of yourself to
come into the experience and co-create
you can offer flowers that signify your
love for it your hopes your dreams it's
really the intention that you have when
you enter into these things and I would
take this back as an example for you and
me in our marriage we had a wedding
ceremony well let's start before then we
had a shamanic ceremonies just the two
of us in Mexico that included a sweat
lodge and a fire and a releasing of
anything that would keep us from each
other any secrets anything that had
happened we were able to put that in the
fire to begin at a at an even ground so
that was the beginning and it was a
glorious engagement and glorious wedding
just the two of us just between us I
remember it so beautifully we had an
amazing meal like on a floating barge
under the stars in Mexico with no one
around you had hidden me messages I
still have the shell you gave me from
that moment and I have a hawk feather
that was given to us by the shaman who
told me that was given to him by his
grandfather so that was the beginning of
this relationship between rich and Jew
and Julie and then we had like the
spiritual world concert of all time that
was the most magic one of the most
magical days I've ever been alive it was
on our land beneath the house with our
boys I was pregnant with Malthus and we
had African wedding singers and
Chandler's and bhagavaan das did the
fire ceremony and we had gospel singers
and it was absolutely magnificent the
clouds actually formed the shape of like
angels in the sky it was crazy crazy
beautiful night then all those years
after that when we almost you know lost
everything and
almost felt like we didn't make it
through our trials we then renewed our
valves with our children then after we
had had the two girls and so we had a
ceremony with just the six of us and
everybody offered something into this
family marriage it was still one of the
most beautiful days of my life you read
me something that day that literally
slayed me it opened my heart up and
touched me at such a deep level that I I
was literally melted in every single
layer of my being I strung garlands for
us we each had flower like Garland's
that I had done and now cutting to 15
years what did we do on our 15 year
anniversary we went and had a ceremony
we ignited what the future holds for us
talked about our intentions what we want
to do together what you want to be I
think my question to you is what would
you like to experience for the next
phase of your life not what are you
going to give me but what do you want to
experience and so we've made that
commitment to each other in that way and
I'm old enough now to look in the
rearview mirror and see I did those same
practices with so many things in our
life so many and they do work there is
energy in that powerful powerful energy
and that's available to all of us what I
hear in that is a couple things I mean
first of all I don't know if you
differentiate between ritual and
ceremony I guess they're sort of the
same thing but there are certain
instances in which kind of creating
formality around a ceremony is
appropriate like it's a wedding or a
renewal of vows or our anniversary but
then there's also this practice of
bringing ritualistic behaviors into your
daily life so that it becomes part and
parcel of just kind of how you approach
the world so the idea of every morning
you know greeting the day with
you know whether it's you know taking a
walk in nature and and focusing your
attention on on something that you want
to more deeply express in your life you
know kind of cultivating the love and
the energy and the intention around that
is something that you don't have to
create a lot of formal structure around
it's more like a mindset a frame of mind
and a daily habit that becomes
ritualized and ultimately contributes to
the manifestation of whatever it is that
you're seeking yeah so I would say those
ceremony those points that I was giving
those examples that's a that's a true
ceremony those were sort of milestones
and those moments that were
astrologically important or important in
our timeline of evolution ritual ritual
I would say would be more the daily you
know more the daily thing that you do so
for instance just two quick things when
I wake up in the morning when my feet
hit the ground my feet touched the
ground I bow down and kiss the floor
basically that's my first act of the
morning my last act of the morning is in
meditation in bed rising up on my knees
and extending my arms to the heavens
with gratitude for everything I've
experienced and then there's a bow down
after that and a release of every
triumph and every tragedy and if you
have to articulate what you get out of
that what does that mean to you and how
does that impact your life it's a it's a
meaning it's a deep meaning for life
it's a connection it's a reminder of the
fact that I am part of the earth that I
am here as part of a an expression and
it's a reverence and an honoring for my
very life for the very life force that
is pulsing through this magnificent
instrument which houses our spirit so
it's a it's an act of reverence
an act of devotion a reset in a way to
to me remembering that I honor that
which is unseen and when you say unseen
what does that mean to you it means
spirit soul I mean there's you know
different people have different
definitions for that so I won't get into
like the semantics on it but basically
that that part of the life force which
is not embodied in this physical body
but which is co-creating and interacting
with me always yeah you know over the
years you're the one who's always been
the motivating force behind all of the
kind of more other kinds of like formal
ceremonies that we've done you know
annually we'll get together around the
fire and we'll write down you know
things we want to let go of and put them
in the fire and you create this kind of
ritualistic you know kind of shamanic
environment around that that gives it
weight and gives it meaning and I think
those are really beautiful expressions
of of this human experience that we're
having and you know to kind of speak to
what I mentioned earlier we really have
moved past this in our in our modern
culture you know we don't we don't you
know we have bar mitzvahs and bar
mitzvahs and we have christenings and we
have these kind of you know ceremonies
that are trapped in religious dogma and
I think for a lot of people they kind of
go through the motions of these things
like bla bla bla but they don't have
that that that intention behind them or
I'm not saying everybody I'm sure for a
lot of people they do but I think to the
extent that we can create our own
rituals that work for us and and treat
them with the same kind of reverence and
sacred energy that they really are are
powerful you know they're powerful
touchdowns and and ways of remembering
and ways of achieving clarity over you
know who you are and and you know where
you've been and where you want to go
yeah definitely and I mean the thing is
is if if you if you are in a religion or
experi
religion and it's making you feel
expanded and free then that's perfect
for you
so it's you know everyone is completely
different I'm just speaking to those of
us that have felt oppressed by religion
or confined by religion or sullied by
religion shamed you know those type of
things so in spiritual awareness there
isn't shame there isn't guilt there's an
expansion so you know that is what we're
experiencing by tapping into that force
how do you think we're doing in our
marriage how do we think well you know
actually was gonna tell you so I have
this thing when I read a book when I
read a book I just open it up to
whatever page randomly draws and then it
gives me the message that I need in that
moment and it actually works all the
time like a hundred percent I understand
this at all
so today rich was like you know are we
gonna do we have something decided or
are we just gonna wing it or what's
going on I was like yeah I don't know
what you mean I was like let's just go
turn the mics on so I came in to the
podcast room which I had this is the
first time that I'm sitting at this
table and and I picked up he has the
Prophet by Kahlil Gibran and I opened it
up spontaneously to a page and so I like
to read it to you all right so it says
then almitra spoke again and said and
what of marriage master and he answered
saying you were born together and
together you shall be forevermore you
shall be together when the white wings
of death scatter your days I you shall
be together even in the silent memory of
God but let there be spaces in your
togetherness and let the winds of the
heavens dance between you love one
another but make not a bond of love let
it rather be a moving sea between the
shores of your souls fill each other's
Cup but drink not from one cup give
another of your bread but eat not from
this give one another of your bread but
eat not from the same loaf right you get
it I'm not eating from your loaf that's
clear sing and dance together and be
joyous but let each one of
you be alone so that's a very same
famous passage that is read at weddings
but I just randomly opened that up and
we were gonna talk about our marriage so
there you go I think that that very well
encapsulate it's kind of how we're
approaching this next phase of our
relationship as two people who have been
together for twenty years it was
interesting I put up this video that
that Reece shot and edited the other day
called why I live in a tent right it was
just a really quick kind of fun like
explaining like why I've been sleeping
in a tent for two years and I kind of
when we were shooting it I spoke to the
question of you know what does Julie
think about this and like are you are
you in the doghouse did she kick you out
of the house or how does this impact
impact your intimacy in your marriage
and I answered that and then it just
didn't make sense in the in the edit of
the video so we left it out so in the
comments like that's all anybody wants
to know everybody has all these opinions
about what this means and how our
marriage must be on the rocks and and
and this sort of thing so that's just
one aspect of this place that we're in
right now where we are deeply bonded yet
living in and and supporting each other
yet living independent lives yeah I mean
I would say it has in fact been always
the way we were bonded mm-hmm so it was
never but I think we've grown into a
comfort level with it that's new mmm
or a little bit more matured maybe but
maybe I don't think so it wasn't feeling
any different to me
really no not for my not from my
perspective so what is your perspective
well I feel like that's how we came
together to begin with it was never like
you complete me that was never our sure
we were never that it was like you know
I will celebrate you as you realize all
your dreams that's sort of the tagline
of our marriage right it was never I
expect you to do X Y & Z for me I don't
think no no no so yeah it's pretty
amazing actually for me to sit here and
of course I didn't read any of those
comments but for you to tell me that
people said that about our marriage and
you know how much reaction I have to
I don't know 0-0 like literally there is
nothing living in me well that stuff
doesn't bother me at all because they
have they don't know so like why would
that bother but it's cool because it's
an indication of the clarity and the
truth of where we really are because if
we were in trouble or we were not up you
know not honest about certain aspects
you could never post something like that
you know what I mean it would be way too
vulnerable so yeah I mean that just
works really really well for us
I think we're and we're both incredibly
independent we're also having this sort
of Alchemist a ssin of extreme
polarities between you and me how
completely different we are and that
causes a friction that has been causing
creating an alchemy and an evolution
between us and I now don't find you as
polar extreme as I did before
we're annoying well that's part of it
I'm sure that goes both ways yeah so I'm
sort of feeling like we're starting to
sort of become same like a sameness of
metal metal
Emme TT le you know like it's like the
passage from the Ramayana that I that I
read to you that I sent to you on our
eighth wedding anniversary where it
talks about how we've been battered by
the shores and the waves of life and
we've come into a certain Beauty a
ruggedness of nature that is only
achieved through those experiences of
life and so right now I mean for my
sodden and what I do it's like I don't
want you in my bedroom like first of all
I'm doing stuff in my sleep State I'm
processing energy I'm in my own
exploration so I need that container so
that I can develop myself in the manner
that I meant to same way you need your
own spaces and one of those spaces just
happens to be a tent yes the tent which
I love but I will just say for the
record I mean our intimacy is actually
extraordinarily well
and it's still amazing to me that we
could be together this many years and
they're the plus for me for him being in
a tent on a daily basis is when we're
together it's like being with my
boyfriend for the first time every time
mm-hmm sorry for the sharing too much I
like that yeah no that's that's a good
answer and I think that's accurate like
I I share that that perspective you know
neither of us are people who like need
to be by each other's side 24 hours a
day but when we do come together it has
to be special we have to be present and
we can make that you know that intimate
time mean a little bit more I think and
so it works for us maybe it doesn't work
for other people out there but it's been
working for us quite well and that's all
that matters yeah so but let's let's
explore this subject of relationship a
little bit more deeply I mean there's a
lot of people look everybody is in some
kind of relationship with another person
in some form or another whether intimate
friendship family whatever and I think
that relationships are the root of the
majority of most people's struggles and
pain so as somebody who has started you
know working with other individuals even
counseling people and hosting these
retreats and and working with people on
a pretty intimate level let's unpack
this subject of relationships and and
where you see commonly people miss
stepping or getting themselves into
situations that are unnecessarily
provoking that kind of suffering
well the biggest suffering is buying
into the prince/princess paradigm in
whatever form even if it's same-sex or
you know or not
is thinking that another is going to
rescue you or complete you if you're in
that paradigm and that's where you're
beginning in a relationship you're gonna
experience that it's not true that that
just doesn't
work out and I would say that in
relationship and in really every single
situation every single challenge that
comes up the answer lies within your own
being so the the resolution of it is
only happening inside your own awareness
so no one can make you feel another way
or act another way or experience an
event
another way than you so it's your own
self and if we can remove whatever we're
projecting onto our partner of anything
that they need to act a certain way to
make you happy or make me happy if I can
remove that I I can say right off the
bat over 50 percent of the conflict will
simply disappear it's very difficult I
think most people when they're searching
for a partner they're innately attracted
to another human being that that
transcends like their conscious
awareness it's their pain body yeah you
see this all the time like people will
end up with that person who basically
mimics the behavior patterns of whoever
caused you pain as a young person right
and you perpetuate this pattern and
you're not even consciously aware that
you're choosing that but that's what
your pain body is going to find that
pain body and the other person that
matches up perfectly and you're meeting
each other's you know sort of unhealthy
needs in that regard and I think it
takes a lot of introspection and and
internal work to be able to first of all
recognize that in yourself and perhaps
it takes a couple bad relationships
before you become intuitively aware of
that and transcend that to find the
person that will that will meet you in a
healthy way
right because often we think we are
attracted to a certain person because of
reason X but it's really reason why that
is propelling you in that direction
yeah so what I would say it's taking
responsibility for your own love taking
responsibility for the way you feel
inside of your being that takes a level
of maturity and if you aren't ready to
what will happen is what we do is he at
human as humans as we meet somebody and
we're like you you know what all the all
the hormones are flowing or whatever the
love endorphins and then we project an
image on to the person that's coming
from our own inner experience which has
nothing to do with who they are and then
we may marry them or end up with them
and when they turn out to not be the
projection that we placed on the person
then we become angry with them right and
we want to throw them away so but even
backing that up were we're attracted to
that person and then kind of baked into
that is this sense that if if if I can
make this relationship work if I can if
I can get with this person then this is
gonna solve a lot of my problems and I'm
going to feel better about myself and my
life will be better and a lot of things
will be improved as part of that
projection it's a beautiful illusion I
mean listen I'm a hopeless romantic I
love being romantically in love it's
wonderful it's just an illusion it's not
it's actually not true because it's you
complete me it's oh you complete me so
went with your love that I'm everything
no the love is coming from inside so
what I'm saying is is that if you become
disenchanted with that in that person
who's not living up to the image that
you projected in the first place
you'll trade it in and get another
person and then you'll recreate the same
scenario again yeah and at the same time
water rises to its own level right so if
you're in a certain place you're gonna
attract a certain person and most people
look at a potential partner as like
they're trying to step up their life
right like they're looking at that
person as somebody who maybe not
necessarily will complete them but
perhaps has certain qualities that that
person wants in their
life but instead of looking at like I
need that in my life so I'm gonna get
that what if you flipped that equation
and said I'm gonna become the person
that I would like to be with
in other words raising your own
watermark so that you're at that level
of the person you're trying to attract
to becoming the person that you're
trying to attract as somebody who might
actually be a good partner for that well
that's it I didn't say that very Ellen
yeah I got it I mean you're right people
say oh you know he married up or she
married up so it is something that's in
the culture and yeah if you had the
maturity and you had the awareness to
develop yourself into the bean into your
most authentic amazing self then you're
gonna have the opportunity to pair with
somebody who meets your level absolutely
true the thing is is that most people
aren't in that space most people are in
sort of like knee-jerk relationships
where their pain body attached to
somebody and you know sort of you have
the same level of trauma I mean you and
I have alcoholism and our families so
there's something about our humor the
way we joke around it's got alcoholism
in it like that's part of its part of
the program it's part of the way that we
you know our families interacted and we
identified and that's familiar so when I
meet you and I talk to you it's like oh
yes the same humor I have you know which
is still awesome but I guess what I
would say is in relationship is where we
have really one of the greatest
opportunities because it ignites it in
your face over and over and over again
it's much easier to be single and go
live in a cave than it is for you to be
you know in a modern relationship so
what I would say is if you're in a
relationship and you're running you know
up against the edges use it like it's a
beautiful tool and whether you end up in
it forever or some people tell me you
know my first marriage failed
and I was like auric completed the
contract completed it's not failed you
know and then they're like oh yeah I did
get my kids out you know my kids did
come into the world or you know it's not
about like an end point like well you
made it to your whole life and your
marriage was a success it's like it's a
live
breathing entity you know there are days
that you and I think about leaving each
other probably or you know it's like
it's like it's moving all the time you
have to check in like what's going on
it's a living thing so it's about being
in the flow and understanding that you
know relationship is a wonderful place
for transformation because it will
reflect all of your issues right back at
you yeah I think that that subject of
stasis and flow is incredibly important
and how we think about our relationships
to other human beings but it's also
applicable to everything I mean I talk
about this all the time with respect to
alcoholism
there is no stasis like every thought
you entertain every interaction you have
with another human being every behavior
that you manifest is either moving you
towards a drink or away from a drink
there's no cruise control like there's
no there's nothing static ever in
anything not in my relationship with you
not in my relationship with my
alcoholism or anything everything is in
motion this table feels solid but it is
molecules that are spinning and moving
in imperceptible ways everything is in
flux all the time and I think if you can
adopt this perspective that everything
is impermanent and that everything that
you do say how you are is moving you
towards what you desire or away from it
and the greater appreciation you can
have for the fact that your
relationships are always in flux and are
always a reflection of how you're
approaching them then I think it allows
people to have a greater appreciation
for what is most important
yeah that's beautifully said and just
sort of ties it back into how we began
the podcast and that's what I'm saying
it's like everything is moving energy
and we are co-creating some experience
all the time we're casting spells with
our words we're you know we're changing
scenarios with our thoughts with our
actions
and so ceremony is a way to connect with
that unseen energy that is a part of
that energetic experience as it starts
to move in shape and so it does mean
something if I've taken a moment and
held your hand and gazed into your eyes
and stated out loud to the universe and
to your heart that I love you that I'm
committed to you and I'm here to stand
witness to your glorious expression and
evolution and that I am I am here and
I'm giving you that voice that means
something it's not nothing it means
something deeply and so it's those acts
and those little things or ritualistic
things that we do throughout the day and
the weeks and the days and the months
that create a vision you know it takes a
life to become the seeds for our life we
planted many many years ago and there's
been countless ceremonies ones we've
even forgotten that we're just you know
the the six of us out by a fire or you
know some sacred event or something like
that it that we were we were cultivating
the energy for what our relationship is
what our marriage is what our you know
creative expressions are and what our
family life is we've been doing that all
along with consistency yeah and it's not
a quid pro quo thing no doing this for a
long time and it doesn't it doesn't pay
off in this you know mathematical
equation sort of way and it's not
immediate and it it doesn't show up in
the way or in the form that you would
like it to or when you would like it to
but I think it's more of a mindset and
how you approach your life that that
that that provides your life with
greater depth and meaning just meaning
yeah that meaning in that connection
definitely and I think that also this is
just to share a little bit more about my
benched to month sort of inner
experience that I've been in I was
really struck profoundly over the amount
of content that is being given into
the collective and knowing that thoughts
are things and that technology takes up
space it's like when you feel into the
planetary grid or what's happening
around the earth with all the output
that's going out there I felt a real
need for discernment discernment for
what information I'm I'm associated with
what am i participating with and how is
that in alignment with my divine design
and what is the highest use and so I
felt very sort of I was given pause
actually because I've been experiencing
and this in this time the beauty of
having actual physical human friends and
support in my life imagine that imagine
that so I was working with my yoga
therapist Michael Manfredo
who's just a master at the body and he
said he basically delivered me like a
Zen sword little you know explosion into
my psyche and it went like this I was
just trying to stretch my leg in a way
and I was in my bedroom and I said oh my
you know my leg won't reach though I'll
move the mat and he said to me or we
could move the bed and that just hit me
so profoundly at so many levels and I
kept hearing this tape in my head for
days afterwards where I would say to
myself I dedicated my life to moving the
bed and I was aware of the limited
perspective that we have in our you know
maybe human self of really what is going
on and really thinking about fake news
and how we're creating these pockets of
experience on Instagram and we think the
world is colored this way and in fact
there's a whole nother color happening
in another another area and I was just
given pause actually great pause in
addition being at revitalize this
wellness summit in June which was
extraordinary I was asked to give the
blessing along with Shawn and Erick
which was beautiful and and I also was
taken aback
the focus of mental mental illness and
mental health being on a trajectory of
wanting to get it to the visibility that
cancer has in 15 years and this is like
we're trying to solve problems from a
way of thinking that is obsolete that is
that is proven that it is not working so
explain to me your your negative
reaction to the idea of a spotlight
being on mental illness in the way that
it is on cancer so what we need is and
this is what what was brought into
awareness is we need tools and
techniques to facilitate humanity and
clearing their trauma because all these
diseases and all these illnesses and
imbalances are a spiritual crisis it's
it's where it's originating so if we had
this this connection this deep
connection we would understand that all
life is divine and we would understand
the power of thoughts and things and
ancestral traumas that are lodged in the
body so the way that we become well the
way that we enter into a state of
expansion is not by focusing on the
thing that we don't want so you could
use cancer as a subject and I apologize
in advance for anybody who has
transcended cancer or become healthy or
even used you know Western methods you
know it's all appropriate in in
different individuals experiences but
I'm not one I'm not marching for cancer
I'm not wearing a pink ribbon to bring
awareness to cancer I'm bringing my life
into awareness of spiritual connection
which is beyond any pill pharmaceutical
and so this is the problem because we
have to be mature enough to stop playing
that game and it's difficult because
there's been a lot of suffering and
there's a lot of trauma around it I
don't see that as the
through so what I was seeing is mental
health being presented at the biggest
wellness summit in the country or maybe
the world and the trajectory was in 15
years we'll have enough focus on it you
know the same amount of awareness it's
cancer but is there a cure for cancer
yet and how many billions of dollars are
being made by pharmaceutical companies
and where is the money in the line of
the whole thing so well I think there's
a there's it's worth exploring this a
little bit more in depth I mean my I
kind of see that a little bit
differently in that to be sure you know
I'm of the perspective that you know
mental health is it's not everything but
it's almost everything and we we are in
the midst of a spiritual crisis of
consciousness right now I think that's
driving a lot of the insanity that we
see in our culture and then kind of just
beneath the surface is a tremendous
amount of of you know I don't know if
you'd call it mental illness or a lack
of mental and emotional well-being so
much so that that you and I both know
like you know you can encounter people
that are seemingly high-functioning and
like they got their together and
they're productive and have good jobs
and families and have the two cars in
the driveway and all that but if you can
get them in a trusting place where they
allow themselves to be a little bit
vulnerable and you just poke them on the
shoulder it all comes out and you
realize that we're all carrying to some
degree we're all carrying some form of
trauma or or you know I don't like that
word mental illness but some you know
we're not all completely mentally and
emotionally healthy we all have our we
all have our our battles that we're
waging and things that we're trying to
overcome and I think there is something
to be said for a greater appreciation
for the fact that this is something that
we need to consider in a different way
or at least raise awareness that this is
actually what's going on in terms of how
we
treat that and how we communicate about
that that's a different conversation
yeah I mean absolutely and I get that
part of it and yes mental illness is not
discussed and it's all around us and in
you know every other family that you
come upon has some level you know so it
is what I mean to say is that the
solution is not in the methods that have
not been serving us and so what it did
is it brought into my awareness the need
for spiritual tools spiritual tools that
are free of isms that allow people to
reclaim their freedom and to live a life
of prevention a life of celebration of
true health and wellness and that's in
all areas physically spiritually
emotionally I just don't see the
trajectory it doesn't give me hope to
see somebody say in 15 years
that's too many people for me mm-hmm you
know that's somebody's brother child son
like you know daughter and so it's a
little hard for it's it's difficult for
me because I know by even saying this
you know it's I'm gonna get you know
there's gonna be blowback and people are
gonna be you know like freaking out and
I have to step into a place where I live
my truth you know it's like this is what
I do you know I assist people in
transition I assist people in clearing
trauma I this is my divine design this
is what I do this is what I did for you
this is what I did over all those years
and this is what fruited the
transformation and realization in your
life and you with you and agreement with
me I mean you're we're we're in together
you know at many many many levels I
don't mean that you know you're every
bit as in this with me as I am but what
I'm just saying is it's just a crisis of
spirituality and what I would say is you
know there is a place where you've
watched everything on Netflix and
there's nothing left there is a place
where you've gone to every concert or
you've eaten every chocolate cake like
what then you know it's like there's so
much better
conversation that we had a bunch of
times where it's sort of like alright
well we're in our 50s like everything is
kind of like really another superhero
movie like there anything that we can
get are we just over it now like what's
next where's the meaning where's the
depth yeah and the thing is is the life
is precious you know life is so precious
and sacred I mean this is a profound
moment in history and we need everyone
we need everybody to be more of who they
are so please don't misunderstand I
value and honor everybody's individual
choice to live their like life as they
choose it is their right I just feel
like it is time for us to stop playing
the old record and there's all this
other energy that's available to us and
so let's start looking into that let's
start embracing that and let's find a
way to health and wholeness and wellness
that is merged in spiritual awareness so
it's it's all of the life not just half
of the life so if somebody's listening
to this and they're feeling stuck in
their life they feel like they're ready
for some form of transformation whether
physical emotional mental or spiritual
you know one of the things that that
that I've realized is that there's this
cavernous gap between information and
action you know you go to the airport
there's 8,000 self-help books on the
shelf like obviously people love this
stuff they love to read about self-help
they want to learn more about how they
can change their life in positive ways
whether its financial or interpersonal
or what-have-you and every month there's
a new crop of these books right there's
an insatiable audience for this
information and yet when you canvass the
population you see a lot of people who
are suffering in all of these different
ways who are still hamstrung paralyzed
and unable to
put that information presuming it's good
information into action in a way that
catalyzes that transformation that that
we all seek and this is getting back to
what I would answer is this need for
personal skin on skin contact
we need actual human beings that are in
our communities that are you know that
have mastered some aspect of
consciousness whether it's a yoga
therapist whether it's an acupuncturist
whether it's a physician of Chinese
medicine I have you know a body worker
who is an artist that's been working
with my body for 10 years one of my
closest friends Sion you can't get this
on social media you can't get it in a
book there's no hacking there's no tips
it's like in order to really mature
spiritually you have to go through the
experiences and I also think in
spirituality it's quite interesting how
we have this this program inside of us
that makes us not want to pay for
anything spiritual right so the minute
somebody wants to charge something
there's a recoil like Oh careful yet
you'll go pay your dentist you know
twenty thousand dollars to fix your
tooth but a skilled spiritual therapist
can accomplish maybe twenty years of
therapy and just a few sessions or maybe
even one session so it's like we're
working with energetic s-- it's actually
an energetic and so I would say reach
out in your community you know look find
you know try to commune with somebody
you know I am doing limited personal
sessions and that's not why you know I'm
talking about this but you can't email
me there's only one of me and I am
teaching retreats now you know
one-on-one retreats I am working on a
program that I will be able to share
that will be something that you know the
population at large can follow that's
one of the reasons why I've taken the
break but I'm really discerning how to
distill it down in the most simple way
so that somebody can take these tools
and go oh my my dad is dying what do I
do you know how do I present for that or
I've been diagnosed with terminal
disease how do i process
that and I want to also just make sure
that it's clear everybody's journey is
unique to them and them alone
it is about taking self-responsibility
there is no one-size-fits-all there is
no not that it doesn't exist so you have
to take responsibility for your life
just how we've been talking about with
health and with not eating processed
foods and not drinking you know milk or
dairy you know you have to take your own
responsibility no one's going to save
you you have to do it but if you're
committed to that and you're committed
to know yourself there are many
beautiful people alive on the planet
that are offering support in that way
one of the things that I love about this
podcast is that it's creating community
[Music]
it's creating a community of like-minded
individuals many of which feel alone in
their community like they're not you
know we live in Los Angeles like these
resources are abundant and accessible to
us but if you're living in a remote area
where you know the conversations that
you're having at the local coffee shop
you know don't reflect this kind of
thing and and there is no Scion
bodyworker
you know that that person is going to be
able to access in their community you
know what do you say to that person and
are there like some online resources
that you can recommend or places that
you go where you can learn more about
these ideas and perhaps find you know
people who can you know serve these
these goals for you in your own
community I guess what I would say is
those people do exist in your own
community and the same way with
spiritual awareness or exploration when
you turn your face to the divine to the
unseen it will meet you 1,000% so I will
say search go ask go find that
grandmother that is the you know is a
medicinal healer that you know is hidden
down the street start asking once you
have the will do you remember how you
used to tell me like wouldn't matter
what party we would walk
in two and you would say you know now
babe it'd be good for you like not to
talk
you know don't say anything about your
experience last night and I would
literally walk into these parties and
the one person that was like me would be
standing next to me in three minutes
later we'd be in a full-blown
multi-dimensional conversation and for
the record that came off like I try to
edit you know I'm trying to like
mansplain or something like that like
please you know but you had like a
comfort like yet so people are like
really not like right if I could explain
and not mansplain what I would say is
look Julie the Julie that you're hearing
right now is a rather tempered version
of Julie like she's out there like
you're out there in a big way and you
can go all the way to the mat how about
some pretty out-there ideas and so my
own personal this is a reflection of me
not you like my own insecurities like oh
my god like Julie like goes down the
rabbit hole like talking to person acts
like like they're gonna think like you
know she's crazy I must be great you
know that's my own like let's
be clear right okay my own insecurities
and all of that but I do admit like I
copped you like yes like it's like if
she goes starts that like it's like whoa
you know like what's she gonna say next
exactly but normally I would find the
vibe of the person so I just offer that
and because of that reason it's really
not appropriate for me to share certain
resources online because it just
wouldn't be appropriate to the mass but
what I would say is if anybody's feeling
like you want more information you can
just email me directly and then I'll
feel into your energy signature and I'll
offer something that's specific for you
you want to give your own oh yeah so my
email is Srimati music at gmail.com s RI
ma ti music at gmail.com also I am doing
a retreat called beloved at Miami's
sacred space and it's November 8th to
the 11th of this year it's an amazing
program three and a half days if you
want to come and work with me one on one
I will be there also I'm doing
my first self-mastery course this is a
very exclusive life activation it's in
fact me going into ceremony and
activating facilitating for you the
expression of your highest divine
mission much in the same way that I've
done for rich for myself and for my
family this is taking place on Gozo in
the month of October October 9 Moulton
goes o near Malta it's the island next
to Malta so you fly into Malta October
10 to 13 I'm only accepting eight people
it's a very exclusive mastery group if
you feel like that's your divine
appointment you can call me as well and
I'll ask you to write something up for
me and we'll see about that
that was some good self-promotion sorry
what you asked I mean I was like oh my
god ya know and I mean the other thing
is true I mean truly the reason that
I've taken this break is I'm literally
in the biggest research moment of my
life I've this level this need for
discernment is it's in my veins like I'm
I'm feeling they need to be explain what
you mean by discernment when you say
discernment you're talking about your
relationship to the world in social
media discernment is what what energy am
i sharing what am i doing why am i doing
it and is it in the highest divine
alignment I'm keenly aware of
personality programs right now I can
actually see them as separate energies
and people it's very weird I'm I'm
wondering like I don't want it I don't
want to create more karma for myself
obviously and I don't want to share
things that are not landing the way that
I want them to or that are not the most
effective so I'm looking for the
simplest most efficient way for me to
express myself authentically so that is
going to be divine through line is going
to be reborn and it's going to have a
new format you haven't podcast it in a
while I had to put a bow caucus in like
two or three months whoa which is crazy
because I love that forum but it's
really really important for me to get
my bearings so I'm gonna be sharing on
that a lot I'm gonna develop a program
which allows people to deal with trauma
how do you deal with trauma my clients
that come to me they always tell me
their biggest darkest secret and let me
just tell you this culture is rampant
with sexual abuse addiction violence
it's just you know so many people are
dealing with so much trauma and it can
be cleared easily we can disconnect from
these energies and claim the freedom of
who we are so that is my heart in my
intention when I speak about these other
paradigms that they have to come down
and we have to step into our spiritual
power we have to the other thing is is
that I'm working on a new body of music
because the music doesn't take any mind
you wouldn't have to subscribe to it you
would just hear it and the vibration
would then have an activation for
whatever whoever my tribe is whoever is
vibing with me whoever feels a line or
is listening to my voice who's like
feeling yes if you don't feel that then
you should go far away and find someone
else like please like it's there's so
many people in so many different
energies you know on the planet that you
should be aligned with only that which
truly resonates with who you are and so
I have no attachment to no opinion about
anything other than I am fulfilling my
life mission and now that I have a lot
of things sort of in play and you know
you're launching into your next amazing
expression and all the amazing work that
you've done babe over these years it's
really extraordinary it's just
extraordinary and I know because I read
all the letters that you guys sent it
send in to him and it's it's been an
extraordinary light in Lantern for so
many people and so thank you for
everything that you've done I appreciate
that and and and like I said at the
outside it's been amazing to watch you
kind of bloom blossom and grow and we've
been talking for you know I don't know
an hour and 15-20 minutes and we haven't
talked at all about you being a vegan
chef
vegan cheese or any of the things that
that people traditionally know you know
about you or when they think about you
that's what they that's the Association
like you're really kind of that's a
that's a part of who you are but the
real essence of who you are I think is
is what you've conveyed today yeah it's
it's it's it's been again like a rebirth
I'm sort of collecting other aspects of
my of my life form and one thing that
I'm really excited about is that I've
stepped into a collective with some
extraordinary artists who are all very
very developed fashion designers and I
can't really speak about it right now
except I have a vision for future
couture movement and and so I've been in
you know in process that's one of the
big things that's been coming through
and it's a it's a relief it feels like
water to my cells some of you may not
know what I was a fashion designer and
had my own collection my own hundred
piece collection for quite a few years
and it's it's just in my blood it's who
it's who I am and I always talk about
searching for Sugarman when they find
Rodrigo and he's painting houses
yeah Rodriguez sorry and he's painting
houses but he's dressed like Bob Dylan
I'm like do you dress like a rock yeah
I'm like dude that's my dude like for
sure so again it's like in this
spiritual exploration it's it's
embodying our life is about cherishing
and honoring every part of your
personality and that's a part of my
personality that I love and adore I love
it and these other artists friends of
mine they they love and adore fashion as
well and so so that's been a super
exciting opportunity because fashion has
the potential to shift culture and so
I've got some really cool ideas and
they've got some really cool ideas and
energetics on how we could do that and
it feels awesome to be in a club with
three people that I adore so completely
as these three individuals so they'll be
more about that but it's been oh and the
other thing that's crazy is that our
daughter math as a starting art school
next week and so
we're gonna be commuting east of
downtown and one of us staying downtown
with her and aloft life is gonna change
yeah
but as a as a part of that and Tyler my
son was telling me you know mom it's
gonna be great because it's gonna
reignite all your art your artistic you
know expression and I used to draw and
sculpt and paint and haven't been doing
that for quite a while so I actually
pulled out my drawings from under my bed
and math has helped me edit it and I'm
just feeling so alive in every single
aspect of my being but don't worry we
are launching cheese that is coming so
so stay tuned with that but anyway it's
a it's a glorious time to be alive and
I'm super happy to be here and to be
your beloved partner from afar from afar
as you're in the tents then you feet
across from me right now I know all
right well we got a we got to wind this
down parting words for the person who
still suffers what I would say parting
words and a thing that I if I can do
anything in my expression in this life
it is to provide the possibility of
another way the possibility of another
perspective and what I would say no
matter what you're struggling with no
matter what action has manifested in
your life be it addiction be it you know
anything
any imbalance that has been plaguing you
I would just tell you that I am holding
the vision of your purest essence for
you and understand that your action is
not you many times we are processing
these attributes for our ancestral lines
and a lot of it is hereditary some of it
is core foundational to who you are as a
being but I would just say that you are
a divine precious expression of
consciousness and I will hold you in
that vision until you can feel it for
yourself and is there anything that that
person can do in the meantime I think
it's the relief
I think the recognition it's a
recognition of knowing of knowing that
they are so much more than their
experience that was what was what I was
trying to offer on that statement yeah
all right well pleasure to spend a
couple hours with you beautiful to be on
the RRP love you babe if you guys are
digging on Julie aka Srimati you can
find her at Srimati on Twitter and
Instagram
Srimati comm is your website divine
through-line is the podcast your even
the hell you sure you gave your email
address how you're gonna get a bunch of
emails a Srimati music Srimati music at
gmail.com yeah that's good cool it's
best tight you want to take us out okay
namaste
[Music]